[Music]
hey folks
welcome back to the dark horse podcast
live stream number
74. the cats are receiving sustenance on
the back counter and we are preparing
to answer your questions we had one cat
who was confused as the nature of
jumping let me guess which cat was
confused
indeed except it was also the cat who
managed to vault herself
like eight feet vertically onto the top
of the cabinets the other day so
yep i don't know she's an unusual one
yes she is all right
here we go no ads this time no none
um we got three questions from last time
we got a discord question
we didn't have many questions in super
chat last hour so we will hopefully be
able to get to
this hour super chat questions pretty
quickly relatively quickly
let's just jump right in well evolution
ever
this is again from episode 73 will
evolution ever produce another
human-like species and if so what do you
think our reaction to that would
be well i'm so tempted to just be
literal in response to this one say
um exactly human-like
no human-like will ev every
characteristic
of humans be reproduced somewhere yes
what will our reaction be we will never
encounter them
this is all undoubtedly happening across
this incredibly vast universe of ours
were we to encounter them well a
i think the degree of difference between
us and what we would encounter would be
substantial enough that we would be
flabbergasted and i am constantly
annoyed
at hollywood's failure to produce
sufficient levels of distinction to be
plausible
they are limited by the fact that
they're using human actors
yes i mean i do i do think there's a
failure of imagination for sure
as you know this this topic is near and
dear to my heart and i think a lot about
what um
conscious beings might look like in an
entirely different evolutionary
uh trajectory and it might well be
totally unrecognizable to us um but
you know other than like i feel like
doctor who did a tremendous job with
this
actually um but uh but generally
if if you want the aliens to be ones
that humans are interacting with
over and over and over again and be sort
of part of the plot line they're going
to be played by
human actors and therefore they're going
to end up being kind of humanoid
i'm not accepting any of this nonsense
because
my sense is were we out there
interacting
with conscious critters um they would be
fascinating
irrespective of how different they were
because of their difference and so
i think basically that's not responsive
no it is it's a constraint
of hollywood using um uh human first of
all the constraint is ever
less constraining because cgi and every
other
manifestation allows you to do whatever
you want and
i think the problem is you know i sort
of liked
2001's approach to this
um and my senses but the but i mean i
think
my my point is 2001's approach this is
brilliant
but the alternative form of of
intelligence doesn't show up as a
character to be interacted with
until the very end and even so it's not
really
you know it's it's there's no
conversation going on right there's
there's no you know ongoing plot lines
in which there's engagement with
with the thing whatever it we call it
right
i just feel like the bias in favor of
stories that we know how to tell
completely blinds us to the intrigue of
the stories that we don't know how to
tell and it's
it's this part this part of why sci-fi
in written form is uh is
has a chance of doing this like there's
there's less i
i give no pass to the written science
fiction
the way i will give some pass to um
video form
science fiction because of the
limitations um of using live actors
who have them to look like people sure
yeah
yep all right cool
um what what about our reaction to it b
um
human reaction it go there or not well
it depends it depends on how we come to
know it
i'm a little concerned that the
spectacular nature of that which is
regularly depicted
video games and all these things is
rendering us
hard to impress yeah and yep i think
uh in essence basically we're being
trained
to be agnostic about everything
that we see because so much of what we
see just simply isn't
um so yep yeah unfortunately our
reaction might be
underwhelmed we might be underwhelmed
yeah
have you read stuart kaufman's origin of
order
as a theory of self-organization that
happens despite adaptation is it a good
expansion of neo-darwinism
i will say before you approach that i i
know i haven't i don't think you have
but um are you aware of i feel like you
at one point were aware of some of
kaufman's
thinking over in the space but it's been
a while
and maybe it's not familiar enough to i
don't know what to say about it it's not
a specialty
um i do think
darwinism is an extension of a process
that
um you know basically darwin is what
happens when you take the selective
processes
in the universe and you add heredity
um and so it's like that i know kaufman
has
deeper and different thoughts about it
but i'm not not in a position to comment
yep
what would you do if given 250 million
dollars from a bitcoin billionaire
no restrictions um
start attempting to
[Music]
wield power in the interest of
conserving what we have and making a
stable
civilization i mean i think i would go
pure fourth frontier on it oh for god's
sake
um so brett is saying he would go fourth
frontier
on it um and sorry we have a
cat problem here um
let's get through it man terrible but
um you would go full fourth frontier
on taking that amount of money and yeah
i would figure out what to do
to get the right people on the question
and to
uh enter the political landscape
uh in a way that would allow power to be
wielded
towards building a uh
steady state that fostered human
persistence
and fulfillment and all those things
yeah and just um by fourth frontier you
mean there is no
established uh map or blueprint
um there are there are foothills on
which we can start um but then it's
discovered
in the process of going yeah it's a
navigation question
rather than a blueprint question yeah
okay um the next question is from the
discord server this week
um and um before i read the question
we've been asked to summarize
chesterton's fence before diving into
the question
um so um
we got animal chaos out there it's
really not have you explained to them
where i went
i i wasn't explicit
um yes
an animal of ours worked and now other
animals are interacting with it and our
son is dealing with it as best
someone of his youth and relative
inexperience
he's awesome though yeah i mean we'll
get through this
we'll get through this it'll be fine
okay um
so i'm actually going to read the
question first um and then we'll explain
what chesterton's fence is let me
read the question again so the question
is is there chesterton's fence case to
be made for bullies
they seem to perform some function of
enforcing social norms and correcting
bad behavior our anti-bullying campaigns
throwing out a baby along with a very
nasty bath water if so can we recreate
it without the toxicity of bullying
it's just a terrific question so um the
reference suggestions fence
is um to this um this philosopher
political thinker from the early 20th
century gk chesterton i think
his initials um who observed i should
have pulled it up actually we quote we
quote this
in our book which will come out in five
months
um the idea that if you are walking
along
uh and you you stumble upon a fence
and they said there's two of you and uh
one of you says this fence is in the way
i want to get rid of it
um it is incumbent on um
on the other to say no you can't get rid
of it until you can
establish what it's there what its
function was in the first place
and only at the point that you can
explain what it's for should you
consider getting rid of it because
otherwise you may be getting rid of
something that's actually quite useful
so the question again is is there is
chesterton's fence case
to be made for bullies they seem to
perform some function of enforcing
social norms and
correcting bad behavior and our
anti-bullying campaigns throwing out a
baby along with a very nasty bathwater
if so can we recreate it without the
toxicity of bullying so
i would say absolutely anti-bullying
campaigns often are
taking a wrong-headed approach yes but i
would i would say the way to formulate
this
is that bullying is the malignant
version of something that is not
inherently malignant
nothing important and so i don't want to
defend bullying because bullying
is that fraction that is beyond the
acceptable but
yeah you know everyone
i will speak as a male amongst males
males
tried each other in a particular way
they expose
expose each other's vulnerabilities and
the point is
you're much better off to have your
friends expose your vulnerabilities so
you can work on them and they
don't continue to be vulnerabilities
rather than
um you know to have them kid you into
imagining that you're less vulnerable
than you are
yeah um so anyway that can turn into
bullying when somebody uses this to
wield power against you
that's a very different thing within a
group of of friends
yeah it's important and it's it is in
particular
you know men and women do this
differently and girl boys and girls do
this differently
one another and i mean this is actually
is you know exactly one of the things
that i've been thinking about and
working on lately is
you know how how do the rules need to be
made explicit and how will they change
when you're in mixed sex groups
um rather than have the expectations of
both sexes be that their rules are the
ones that are applying
um but you know what what you just said
is absolutely
how things play out and they play out
well generally
within groups of men yes now i would
also say that where this gets difficult
is that let's say school yard bullies
school schoolyard bullies may in fact be
serving an
important role toughening you up
for adult world bullies right and so the
thing is if you're going to face adult
world bullies the last thing you want is
a school yard
that led you to believe you were better
protected than you were so
even the schoolyard bully even if that
is over into malignant space
getting rid of it may not be such a good
idea
and so anyway i think the answer to your
question is
very simply yes it would be insane
to just simply regard you know it's it's
basically like anesthetizing pain
in imagining that pain is simply
bad and therefore its absence is simply
good
that's dangerous and the fact is
would the world be better off with no um
bullying
or anything that looked like it uh maybe
but the the naive
urge to get rid of it from every context
i mean you know what does this have to
do with a
generation that seems to think that um
words are tantamount to violence right
right oh very much it's sort of the
it's part of the same parcel that awards
gold stars for everything
and that prevents any anything that
feels uncomfortable from ever
approaching the protected space
of um of you know a child's world
totally um and then they emerge
with the body of an adult but the mind
that has never been exposed to anything
that they normally would have been
exposed to
um easily triggered literally easily
triggered
easily triggered yep um and then
so if so can we recreate it without the
toxicity of bullying i think
you know you've sort of you've gone
forth frontier foothill on this by
saying
if bullying is the pathological form of
something
we need to encourage the
non-pathological form and also recognize
that even in some cases
the thing that is even digging into the
pathological form
um has a utility yeah yeah
okay um next question from this last
hour
uh the discord question about bullies it
says was a typo
it was supposed to be about billie's
what is the evolutionary role of
billie's such as capital police officer
billy
evans love and miss you buddy so
i asked you if you knew that was and i
asked you to look it up did you
manage to that's going to be a no
no okay so we don't know who that is but
capital police officers not
the maybe i don't know because
yes i'm uh catching up on my homework
here yes
um say impressive things
um that's not fair dude
sorry this is the one thing i asked you
to do over the break
um so uh yeah um i appreciate that
someone is clearly in the discord and
saw what the discord question was and
and jumped off that so while you're
looking it up i'll go to the next
question billy evans um
next question and we'll come back to
this one u.s
navy is releasing ufo information
possibility of space aliens upsets
evolution as applied to humans
new climate studies say never was a
clarity on earth where humans could live
without technology of clothing fire and
shelter
did we escape from alien lab or
abandoned
um so i don't know anything about the us
navy releasing ufo and foam
um new climate studies say there was
never a climate period on earth where
humans could live without technology of
clothing fire and shelter that's
[ __ ] that's just not true that's
that's not right um catch me up
sorry can't help you with this one um
which one the billy one yeah
okay
i'll read it again the u.s navy is
releasing ufo info
the possibility of space aliens upsets
evolution as applied to humans
new climate studies say there was never
a climate period on earth where humans
could live without technology of
clothing fire or shelter
did we escape from an alien lab or were
we abandoned
so what i said was there's no way that
um there was never a climate period on
earth where humans could live without
technology of clothing fire shelter
that's that's patently
not true right it's just that's that's
that has no relationship to reality so i
don't know what that yeah
new climate studies so i therefore
unfortunately suspect the first
claim too which is u.s navy releasing
ufo info i have no idea what that no
there's been some i don't think i don't
know what that is
um no i can't speak authoritatively on
it um
but i can say there's tantalizing stuff
and we don't know what it means nor
do we know why it's being released um so
okay um so here i find wapo
uh published on april 2nd u.s capitol
police officer william billy evans
killed in the line of
duty and my sense is this is a new story
that we don't know about
yep okay
um and
okay let's go to the next question how
do we solve the intractable feral pig
problem
brett actually doesn't invoke you it's
asking us
the competitive efficiency is supreme do
we resurrect velociraptors to
introduce a viable predator thank you
cannot wait for your book
well let's just say i actually don't
know anything about
the feral pig problem where it is a
problem um
i will say the
the uh invasive species problem is
a doozy yeah it is among the most
difficult
environmental problems that we have it's
very hard once these things
are established to get rid of them and
many
many problems have been compounded by
attempts to get rid of invasive species
so
for example the um
um the what are they
they are not weasels they
are ricky ticky tammy
mongoose mongoose that were released in
hawaii
and jamaica and various places
it's not really such a terrible problem
but there are the manatees in the panama
canal
released to take care of the hydrilla
problem over which they have had very
little influence but
nonetheless they are well fed basically
it's very hard to get rid of an invasive
species
especially with another invasive species
right easier
oh and then there's uh
i remember the cane toad story but in
any case oh yeah bufo mirandas has been
introduced
in um australia um and i think hawaii as
well
and puerto rico i think it's not native
it's native to i think mainly neotropics
yeah
um it's called either the marine toad or
the kin toad yeah the larger
the vertebrate the easier it is to
address
because you can do things like hunt them
out trap them
um a tiny vertebrate or even a moderate
size for the
rodent for example the larger it is the
fewer there are
of course right exactly so easier to
find fewer successful
hunting episodes but i do wonder if
uh ultimately i mean we are basically
destroying habitat after
habitat with invasives and really the
only habitats that are at all immune to
this
are uh mainland tropical habitats which
at least at the level of their
mature tree species are immune to
innovation at least
so far but everywhere else we're
wrecking it
i do wonder if there's not ultimately
some sort of a drone based
solution yeah i don't like it either but
um basically you could have a single
purpose
drone designed to find you know
imagine that you programmed a drone to
identify
eucalyptus trees for example right and
you know it could be that it had to
establish
uh the eucalyptusness of a tree my guess
is you could get the recognition to
absolutely 100 um but if it then
signaled the you know approach of
something that then
properly killed the tree or something
and then you had a crew come in and
figured out how to
you know if it was anywhere near any
structure how to fell it in a proper
direction
conceivably you could recover you know
the andes
which are so thoroughly invaded by
eucalyptus at this point that most of
the native trees have become
extremely scarce um
i don't know but i short of something
like
a very high tech solution it's very hard
to know what to do about things like
english iv right or yup
bufamarinus or eucalyptus or any one of
these things and and the
devastation that comes from uh these
species is incredible
yeah yeah it is
all right next question um
part uh dr heing
regarding your tree thinking thread is
it possible to have divergence or
reversal in the human clade and not
realize it as it's happening given that
evolutionary time hasn't yet passed
how would we know how might this
intersect with google's selfish ledger
concept for human social engineering or
potentially
inevitable bioengineering down the line
as the ccp is now testing and there's a
link to a youtube video that i not have
time to watch
so i'll just say the tree thinking
thread
to which marutia is referring is this
one zac you can show it
um i i don't usually do this
on twitter but this so-called
evolutionary geneticist
said something wrong which is fine um
they were ignorant
um but then they got um arrogant
actually at
our friend dave stevens who um who made
these swords and machetes that we showed
earlier and then he pulled rank
with his credential and that combination
just caused me to say you know what
no we're done here so
um i wrote this thread um in which um i
explained that i was going to go
remedial evolution on him since he
seemed to have missed a lot
and um one of the things i say
i show a couple of um slides from
actually the very first lecture i used
to give in my vertebrae evolution
program showing
you know how to interpret phylogenetic
trees um
and i say which is true that tree
thinking is actually doesn't come
naturally to anyone thinking in
phylogenetic trees really doesn't come
naturally to people and even
you know to be fair to this guy who was
ignorant arrogant and
and pulling rank when he had no right to
um
most people who think that they have
been trained in evolutionary biology
actually don't know how to interpret
phylogenetic trees
accurately and that's a shame i mean it
really does
i think explain a lot of why there's so
much bad evolutionary thinking out there
and i only provide a tiny little lesson
here it's hardly
an entire program in front of revolution
which i use i used to provide
um but that that's what the tree
thinking thread here is referring to
um and so the question which we you know
we're both equally schooled in this
stuff
is it possible to have divergence or
reversal in the human clade and not
realize it as it's happening given that
evolutionary time hasn't yet passed how
would we know
um and i guess the first level of answer
is that
you know we as we have said over and
over and over again is that we are so
much more software than hardware we are
constantly diverging
and reversing mostly you know
progressing but um
regressing and reversing and diverging
and all of these things
but that since it's almost all the
software level it's almost all in our in
our ideas
and our behaviors and our cultural norms
um that it doesn't leave for the most
part changes in
our genetics there are some there are
some things that have left
genetic changes even of late you know
you find for instance um
different ability uh to extract oxygen
from air
among um himalayan people who live at
very high altitude where there's a lower
density of oxygen so that's actually
been
genetically demonstrated but for the
most part the very many changes that all
of us are undergoing all the time
is both evolutionary and not going to
leave a trace genetically
yep makes sense um
was there a second how might this
intersect with google's selfish ledger
concept for human social engineering
or potentially inevitable bioengineering
down the line as the ccp is now testing
do you know anything about either of
those no i i think your answer here is
quite right that in terms of humans
there is genetic evolution that takes
place but
so much has been offloaded to the
software layer that we have to think in
those terms and
because of the way software can move
horizontally
we are also not held to the phylogenetic
thinking in the same
way that we would otherwise be and you
know basically you need that update in
order to think about these things
or it doesn't work but no i don't know
anything about what they're i mean it's
possible i know these concepts but not
by those names right
right often the case right
do men have beards because they were
useful or because chicks dig them
is there a way to determine which
sexually dymorphic traits evolve due to
sexual selection
versus natural selection well not
obvious
um yeah great question probably the
beard thing
had may or may not be the chicks dig
them thing
it may be that it is a
distinguisher between the sexes that is
not
inherently about um
[Music]
favoring them i would say sexual
selection
is effectively diagnosed
by dimorphism but sexual selection is
not the same thing
as mate choice right sexual selection
comes in
several different flavors and so you
have male male competition
which produces things like antlers and
it is not
i don't have them but i thought i'd miss
them all these years
you know usually people check jews for
horns no no not the answer
never my thing nope i was hoping for
antlers
so uh yeah the
the thing is you've got antlers on
various kinds of deer like a moose which
is a deer
it is not obvious it is obvious that the
antlers are the result of males
competing against other males to
displace them from mating opportunities
what is not clear is whether or not
females
are indifferent to the differences
between males
and they will simply mate with the
winners because they are the winners or
the male male competition is doing the
job that female choice would do
right those two things are very
difficult if not impossible to
distinguish
and so anyway what i would say is the
dimorphism
between uh male and female deer
in the form of antlers versus no antlers
and everything but caribou i think
um do female caribou have antlers they
do really
yeah that's going on there not sure
that's an interesting question oh
fascinating
um but in any case the dimorphism both
the size dimorphism and the antler
dimorphism
in deer is clearly the result of male
male competition
but um and so it is the result of sexual
selection but it is not clear that it
has any relationship to mate choice at
all
so what does obviously
beards are not as effective a weapon
as antlers they're too soft yeah they're
too soft
right and flammable well then you just
you have to keep them so close to your
face
not really i've seen some some really
long beards
um but in any case i'm not quite sure
what we're being asked but
the way to tell if a trait is the result
of sexual selection
is dimorphism that doesn't tell you
though that it's about preference
fair enough uh someone says i almost
like ads now storytelling ads keep it up
cool uh what is the evolutionary role of
disgust
do you think it plays a role in our
current hysteria especially in views of
masculinity
um well okay so i've just gone through
a kind of disgust over
the uh our pets exudates yes the pet
reverse peristalsis episode that
would follow the beginning of this
episode of the dark horse q a
yeah um so i'm feeling it a little
viscerally but
anyway the purpose of disgust is to keep
you from engaging things that are
likely to be bad for you probably for
pathogenic reasons
and so you know things that are
disgusting
the smell of a fish that has been lying
in the sun
feces um
you know mayonnaise that is past its
prime whatever so these are all then you
know slightly you know slightly fewer
people but you know a filthy bathroom
right like right you know in different
different thresholds we're like i don't
touch anything in there uh corpses that
have not been
preserved right all of these things are
trigger discussed now relies on
horizontal meat here's what you're
looking for
let's talk about the smells first of all
right lots of smells are disgusting
there's a question about whether the
disgustingness of the smell
is on the producer side or the perceiver
side
right in other words in many cases a
fish for example that is rotting on the
beach
it doesn't give a damn one way or
another whether you're disgusted by it
or you're not right it's going to get it
it's done caring
it's yeah no i'm scared no it sounds
like a throwaway line but it's done
caring
it's done caring it did care
so well but a corpse a human corpse
is not done character not inherently
depending on who it has died among
right and similarly um some
some kinds of poop is actually
communicating something where the
individual who pooped is actually has an
interest in a signal being conveyed
right
so so this is exactly my point is that a
social creature
may indeed have an incentive to
use a signal to warn kin away from
something potentially pathogenic
right it is also true in the case of an
individual they have
an incentive so let's do it this way
a deer dead by the side of the road
it has no particular interest in
conveying to a human
that interacting with its corpse might
be dangerous
right it could conceivably have
that instinct or that uh reason to
convey that
to other deer who might be kin and could
be warned off but because they're not
carnivores
it doesn't need any special yeah
and i don't see it well so so here's my
point
carrion smells bad to us because we're
wired to detect carrion because it's
dangerous
right now you're probably wired to be
able to override that
if sufficiently starving right so it
definitely smells off
well would a prediction of this be that
a dedicated herbivore like a rabbit
wouldn't have an aversion to a carrion
smell
because it's not it's not looking for
meat anyway
and if grasses grow if its food is
growing near where the carrion is it
shouldn't care one way or another if the
meat smells fresh or the meat smells bad
super complex because let's say you're a
rabbit you're attracted to
some grass that's near uh rotting
animal to which you are indifferent but
now
what if the grass is sullied or the yeah
the grass is solid or the jackal
is attack is it right yeah that's second
order risk of second order predation or
right yeah but my point is let's compare
two things
human cadaver and
deer roadkill yep okay
the human has an incentive the cadaver
has an incentive to warn other humans
away from it
and we humans have an incentive to
discover the hazard and be repulsed
right the deer has only one of these two
the deer
has no ins it's done caring
effectively but we are not done caring
about whether or not it is edible meat
or not right if it's just been killed
and it doesn't stink you might as well
pick it up off the road and
you know have venison steaks but if it's
at all
rotten you want to be warned off it and
your repulsion
does that but the point is it's one of
two things it's all user side
on the carry in front on the side it
could be both
um which is which is to say same species
versus different species in part
because same species at least if you're
among individuals about whom you care
historically would have been kin um
there is a greater risk of eating a
pathogen from eating the meat of the
same species than from
eating the meat of a different species
like you can get a prion disease or
something right
yeah right something like that so in any
case the answer to your question if i
remember it correctly is
disgust is about warning you off of
things that are potentially
infectious now there may be disgust that
isn't about pathogenicity but i'm not
immediately coming up with anything but
i would say there's lots of metaphorical
disgust you may be disgusted at
someone's behavior
yeah which is as if pathological right
it's all a metaphor
i think i mean i think at this point
yeah there's a lot of metaphorical
disgust to go around i feel like i
experience metaphorical disgust
every time i go on social media and i
see images
i see people parading around their
children whom they are actively trying
to transition
right i'm disgusted by that and
i'm not i'm not at a personal like
disease risk from that although i feel a
distinct societal risk from this so
um you know one might argue and i might
become convinced that that is not
discussed it's different
but it feels some it feels comfortable i
think it's just using the same
channel yeah right so the point is you
know the
what you're perceiving is very different
but what it triggers
the revulsion is not different and for
good reason
you don't need an infinite number of you
know let's say you know you've got a
pleasure center it can be stimulated
by reading a cool passage or you know
catching a frisbee that was
thrown in such a way that it was
unlikely you would catch it right
two very different phenomena they
trigger something we call pleasure and
it's not
a loose analogy it's like it actually
feels good sorry what was your first i
was thinking i was now i was now
imagining that
that catch what was your first example
um my first example was
what was it hey zach did you hear you
weren't paying attention
no anyway oh my god i feel like i feel
like we should
go into the frisbee again soon yeah
today we should
yeah we should um what was the first
example it was
uh oh reading a passage that was
particularly oh yeah
but very different yeah very different
yeah
and then the second part of that
question was um
do you think the evolutionary world
discussed plays a role in our current
hysteria especially in views of
masculinity
i don't quite i don't see that exactly i
don't see the connection
is this discussed about masculinity
which some people clearly have
yeah maybe but it just seems so
so fake so much of it so it's just hard
to tell like it would have to be
people actually feeling real disgust and
it's hard to tell
what's what yeah um
yeah i agree there's a lot of uh
performative nonsense where people
aren't really disgusted and in fact
many are the opposite right right yeah
so
boys are being given the message that
masculinity is toxic
but um you know girls ain't changed that
much
and they like masculinity right
is spoken or written language up to the
task of managing complexity in 2021
and why not and why not that's exactly
right
okay maybe that's all we need well no
you should say a little bit about it
okay
language is not up to dealing with the
kinds of subtleties
that we are dealing with
and many stuff like the difficulty in
conveying the meaning of quantum
phenomena
for example show us that language is
just a very poor conduit for this sort
of thing
it doesn't mean that you can't
develop a language in which those things
can be conveyed and we do that and
that's the proper role of
university is to figure out what
language we need in order to describe
this whether that's a mathematical
language that describes things
or a you know literal subset of a
language
but what i would point out is that
there's a tension between two things
what i would call terms of art terms of
art are terms you necessarily
need in order to describe things that
are not easily described in regular
language
right um and jargon
which is a unnecessary proliferation of
terminology that's basically territorial
in nature and the point is
no jargon ever god damn it but
in terms of art to the extent necessary
you're gonna have to have them and
sometimes terms of art can be
you know completely elaborate
when you're talking about phenomena that
are really far from our normal
experience and therefore difficult to
convey
and so the really important thing it's
one of these principles like
um the government that governs best
governs least
that does not mean no government right a
[ __ ] would conclude that
i'm tempted not to say anything nasty
about libertarians now so i would just
not even think it um the government the
government's best govern is least
that is to say least amount of
government necessary to do
the job yeah least amount of terms of
art
necessary to do the job and no jargon
right no government for its own sake no
terminology for its own sake
only were necessary to do the job yeah
good
um sometimes i like to spend my
afternoons eating exlax and huffing
nitrous oxide you know just for shits
and giggles
good one and then um
and then we'll move on to this hour's
questions um i don't know what agw
stands for
agw notwithstanding all self-respecting
polar bears are so sick of seal by
summer that they have either egg season
marked in caps on their calendars
following from our uh polar bear
discussion a couple weeks ago
i don't remember yeah global warming
something
something level warning anthropogenic
global warming ah
that's it
okay uh why are indians from india
considered asian on many forms and docks
you fill out not caucasians like they
are in the anthropology world
that is the same set of traits as
lighter skinned caucasians
uh i don't know what the politics
is um you know i think the caucuses are
technically in asia
so there's obviously you know the
boundaries are always blurry the
boundaries are actually blurry but you
know south asia is asia india is part of
asia
i think this is a um lineage
versus geography question and
that in effect the geography
is a proxy for lineage
and imprecise and sometimes wildly
inaccurate right there's a border
somewhere over there
and it happens it's the far side of
india rather than the near side
from the european perspective and maybe
the people who came in and colonized
intentionally drew a line
where they shouldn't have right like we
talked about with like north korea and
south korea and has happened
everywhere basically all of africa had
this done too
likely yes to define uh indians as other
rather than same for political purposes
and then you should know that the
distinction between
asia and europe which seems perfectly
arbitrary and bizarre
to every school child who counts
continents and
sees eurasia is actually naturally kind
of one thing
um but there is actually a distinction
it has to do with tectonic plates
underneath these things you've got two
plates that collided
and that is the reason that we have two
continents rather than one
um but the point is you've got is that i
don't
i mean there are there are plates but
i'm not sure about the colliding because
so i'm just thinking back and i won't be
able to pull them up but like you know
we had pangaea
and then pangaea kind of rifted north
south and you had laura asia
which is north america europe asia and
gondwana which is everything else
and i know a lot more about the
movements of gondwana because it's where
madagascar and south america have been
but larasia
which split ultimately into north
america europe and asia
um europe and asia obviously still
connected they kind of were connected
and i think it's different plates but
i'm not sure that they ever
collided in in you know modern times
meaning like anything like the last 600
million years even
i don't know yeah i don't know either i
don't know either but let's just say
the continent distinction is one of
tectonic plates
whatever their historical relationship
to each other and that
doesn't inherently have anything to do
with lineage and it's especially
unlikely to have anything to do with
lineage in a case where you can move
over land from one to the other
but i mean as long as we're doing
tectonic plates
uh biogeography in fact india was part
of gondwana
right so india um rifted apart from
first from africa between africa and
madagascar yes
madagascar and india were connected so
you know this part of the story i know
well because
i was working at madagascar for a while
thinking a lot about the crazy
distribution of organisms across
what used to be gondwana and now across
the modern land masses where you have
these distributions
um of like you know organisms that are
only the
close relatives are found in like south
america madagascar and india
without africa so like africa rifts out
of gondwana first
leaving south america india madagascar
and australia connected via a then
rather temperate
antarctica through which there are
probably organisms traveling and then at
some point india breaks loose
travels north slams into asia and forms
the himalayas
so it is you know the very distinct
that's obviously
long before there are any people around
but um it is a distinct
it is that is a distinct landmass as
well yeah for sure
yeah um however i don't think we really
answered the question but we
we rift on drifting we did answer the
question the question
is you've got a tectonic geologic
description of land masses and then
you've got a lineage description
but this question asks basically about a
modern political distinction versus an
anthropological distinction
and i don't i don't know you would
expect us you would expect the
anthropologists
it wouldn't be the first time they
disappointed but you would expect the
anthropologist to track the lineage and
not
the geology they ought to
oh you would hope that i thought you
were saying the opposite um yeah you
would you would hope that they had and
it sounds
um sounds like they did yeah it sounds
like they did in this case
the point is the other thing the
political thing
may well have arbitrarily chosen the
geology
to designate peoples because of the
reasons you point to yeah or you know ex
just
external indicators of skin color which
is you know what a lot
a lot of humans do and it's part of why
you know we're so tangled over rice
yeah well the funny thing though is skin
color is like
uh plant habit it's not
phylogenetic it's responsive to light
regime and so
there are lots of dark-skinned people
who are not especially closely related
to each other because they've
developed dark skin in response to uv
radiation crossing through the
atmosphere directly
and so it ought to be a character that
we discount
in phylogenetically diagnosing people
what is your take this is from our
friend echo what is your take on coffee
enemas
hippocrates advocated for enemas
it cleans adherences in the colon allows
liver and kidneys to excrete waste
without circulating through blood
stimulates production of
glutathione s transferase
i don't know i've never looked into
animals yeah i just don't know anything
about it
um it wouldn't surprise me if it made
some sense but it wouldn't surprise me
if it made some sense
either on the other hand i would say
what really makes sense is eating the
right stuff
right eating the right stuff takes care
of a tremendous number of the problems
that you might seek to remedy
with something uh as exotic as an enema
yep that arming sword is really cool
do either of you do martial arts i think
brett would especially enjoy
hima or krav maga
i was thinking you know just giving my
heritage
taking up some jiu jitsu no
you're
we've thought about neither of us do and
um actually when we moved here
our friend peter pagosian was like you
guys should at least bring your boys
down to the studio where i train and
and we're done we haven't done it i mean
we do have coveted over the last
many months i don't think of us as not
having done it i
think of us as maintaining the element
of surprise
he has no idea when we're going to take
him up on that offer and therefore will
not see it coming and so we could get
the jump on him
yeah that's one way of thinking about it
for sure
yes it is
this next question is thoroughly
disgusting but i'm going to read it
anyway i don't know
we've gone from animals to thoroughly
disgusting yes
okay we've gone from discussing disgust
to animals to now what's coming i have
been stealing breast milk from virus
survivors and vax recipients
everyone is urging me to stop is there
any comparable immune boost for my
lattes
i told you yeah all right did i lie no
no you didn't um
i don't think that's a serious thanks
for making a slap yeah i don't think so
either
how did um
poly dna viruses arise and it's all
spelled out as one word i actually don't
i'm not
familiar with that as a as a category
are there free living poly dna viruses
independent of any wasp species
and how often does mutualism evolve
between viruses and their hosts
so the second question sounds like
there's some special thing going on in
wasps
i at least don't know anything about it
um
how often does mutualism evolve between
viruses and their hosts
i don't know but i would expect somewhat
commonly
i would expect it to be rare okay but
but maybe i'm just missing a category
well i guess maybe that's it it's like
you know mutualism
you know you could argue that a decrease
in virulence over time as a virus
becomes adapted to a particular host
uh i guess that's now it's it's just
co-evolution it's not mutualism what do
you got okay
oh no dear okay oh man i wish they'd
chase the deer rather than our cats
they may be that deer was on the move
that would be great
um we still don't have a camera to point
out our window at you guys so i could
point my microphone does that help
um
uh yeah actually i think i was i was
reading uh
co-evolution not mutualism i think
mutualism rare right
yeah yeah but um it's a worthy question
if there were examples yeah i've been
floating i've been floating a new slogan
to replace mega after your criticism
boy miss try again should i try again
yeah
i've been floating a new slogan to
replace maga after your criticisms of
the
again part make america greater than
ever
or mage for short thoughts
um yeah unfortunately you have to as you
can see you have to like
parentheses the than other way otherwise
it's makte
yeah it's a little it's a little clumsy
but
i'm basically in favor of the
recognition that there is much that is
great that it has never been great
for everyone and there is much that has
been great just never for everyone right
that's
that's the point it's not i'm not saying
there is not greatness
but the point is until it's great for
all americans or all populations of
americans
you know what american thinks it's fine
for it not to be great for all
populations of americans
i guess my point would be either we're a
people in which case
that's an uncool condition or we're not
a people in which case it's a fiction to
begin with
there's nothing to make great if we're
not a people so i'm up for anything
that both acknowledges the past
greatness and acknowledges
the duty to make sure that that is
accessible to all
populations of americans and so anyway i
think we have yet to
land on a formulation that's easy
to utilize yep but um
but any something down that road yup
okay
um
this next one has some hebrew in it that
i will butcher if i try to pronounce
um any any chance you can pronounce that
chag samich
yeah happy easter
and jog passage sub each i'm sure i know
i'm butchering that
yeah i'm not gonna help yeah and i know
i know it's hebrew
to you and yours and everyone watching i
think it is we are in passover now
i think uh or maybe it's a you don't
know um
and easter is tomorrow so happy
these holidays to you and to yours and
everyone watching i like the reverse ad
format reminds me that i once got a
manila envelope sent to me inside a
cardboard box filled up with those air
filled bags
really wow
has there been a discussion about
rebooting american unity for 2024
it needs to start now and be on a
campaign for the whole term name
recognition
um yeah there's certainly discussion
about rebooting
unity but unity is not 100 about
elections
it really needs to be about a plan where
there
um is an opportunity to do the patriotic
and
wise thing that is outside the bounds of
the normal unexpected politics and so
yes unity 2024
is a thing but you should expect other
kinds of proposals
sooner excellent
um next question
i recently read about parifisaurus
braziliensis
the brazilian terror bird why do you
think avians evolved to have these
apparently useless appendages for eras
why were they prioritizing rear legs
um
so this is i i actually just quickly
looked it up it looks like it's
you know along the lines of a pureness
which is the elephant bird
now extinct in madagascar but not
extinct for so long that there are still
pieces of the giant eggshells on some of
the southern beaches
basically rendered extinct by people
people haven't been on madagascar for
more than a couple thousand years and
um presumably these these guys were
there
um and then we i mean i think i think
with a pureness which i do know
something about
and presumably for peripherasaurus which
i
had not heard of before now the
brazilian terror board that these are
both going to be extinct members
of the pelegnaths uh
extant members of which include ostrich
emu
cassowary ria so the question
is um effectively why
why once you've evolved wings lose them
and go flightless
i think is the question well probably
it's just an ollometry issue
where these animals the size
had an advantage that was um
sufficient to overcome the
uh the value of flight so if you can
grow out of the ability to be preyed
upon
so there were some very large pterosaurs
um well but
is kiwi yeah i don't know where kiwis
are in that group so they're also piling
us but i don't know if they're derived
within the group that they shrunk after
but kiwis are also island species so
um basically what i would say is um
you know flight one of the advantages of
flight is escaping predators if you
don't have any predators because you're
too ferocious or you're too big
then the value of that decreases the
cost of flight is comparatively high but
i would just say that there's some
combination of ecology
and physiology that
favored uh
favored large size yeah and i guess
so why were they prioritizing rear legs
um
it's interesting birds i'm also
the the name here you often i don't see
the names in such a small font but
the name here is the name of a former
student of mine and it's possible it's
the same person so mary if
if we know each other then cool that
you're asking this question
um and if i'm married if you're totally
different mary then cool that you're
asking this question
also um but
if it is the merry that i had in some
programs you may remember that
one of the problems for tetrapods upon
coming on to land
is that um we you know we have this
lateral form
so can you show the whole thing i don't
have to hold my hand up it's quite so
high yeah so
you know fish are swimming like this and
you come on to land and you're still
moving like this
um but what that means is that because
we have bilateral symmetry with every
move you're crushing one of your lungs
and so you can't actually you have
something called carrier's constraint
where you can't actually move and
breathe at the same time
and so you find for instance lizards if
you've ever spent time actually watching
lizards for a while and watching as they
run and then watching as they're still
um you'll see them breathing really hard
by the oscillations of their throat
because while they're actually running
they're holding their breath
and so there's like there's a few clades
of tetrapods that solve this problem one
of them is frogs
they go you know they start moving in
this direction in this plane
um by extending their um their legs and
various other structural changes to
their skeleton
but then birds and mammals separately
have started moving not in this plane
but in this plane so we mammals are
vertically under
undulating if you think about dolphins
versus sharks
dolphins versus sharks perfect and then
birds
solved this problem by basically
becoming bipedal
which in mammals it's really only us
there are a couple of other sort of
facultatively bipedal organisms but
um you know birds have gone bipedal and
the paleonts the ostriches and
cassowaries and everything of which i
assume the brazilian terrible at this
part are actually pretty basil within
birds
so it might almost have been this like
experimental thing like okay we've now
we've gone up on we've gone bipedal
let's see what else that'll get us like
you know an exploration
of evolution in like okay what are we
gonna do with our legs
now that we're on two legs territory
all right i think i just don't know
enough about it to add to that
okay when we create ai and they become
our
future software only children evolution
what would you think would be most
important to teach them and to not
teach them also please get a crypto
address to send money
thanks for all you do
um so the i i don't know what to do with
the setup of this question
right it will be a disaster if ai
becomes the purpose of anything and i'm
not sure i give a [ __ ] what happens
next um so why don't you take it out of
that context
because i think there is something that
you have to say here um around
what we should be doing um as we get
closer
to fully functional smart ai
in order to protect ourselves yeah
i'm not sure i want to deploy it here
but i do think that there is
a a solution to be had but it isn't so
much about
telling the ai something and hoping they
listen
yeah we can't rely on hoping that the ai
lessons no
uh how many cats do you own do you plan
on expanding your clouder
we have not counted recently
whenever you answer things like that
like you just send entirely the wrong
message about what kind of a person
you are what kind of a household this is
how we engage with our cats
whether or not we've noticed if any of
them have been attacked by coyotes
it's not who we are no we have three
cats
which is the most we've ever had
it's a good number we have often had
three we've often had three
we have very briefly occasionally had
zero occasionally one
more often two yep yeah
three two or three seems like a good
number um one
one isn't enough i would have said one
always gets into trouble although one of
our three cats at the moment would get
into trouble no matter what so
all right um where are we at zac
timewise
all right let's uh let's do a couple
more and then uh
then sign off within something like an
hour here how many
of the scientists in quotes portrayed by
mainstream media for instance neil
degrasse tyson
and m kaku i don't know who that second
person
oh okay have actually done genuinely
interesting work
it seems they rarely discuss their own
work on the television
i don't know for that i think i think
degrasse tyson was doing
um some of his own work early on i mean
he's he's more of a communicator of
science i think that's
that's the typical thing yeah um
kaku is a tougher case i don't i don't
i don't understand uh his quadrant well
enough to know
but i also think that there's an awful
lot of popularizer
i would say dawkins
did his own work absolutely and
in some ways is underappreciated for it
inside the field because his work
is synthesis primarily
um which it can and because it was
mostly presented in book form
frankly it was presented not in the
peer-reviewed literature which is not
what you're supposed to do in fact
almost none of his work right was in the
peer-reviewed literature which does not
count against him in my book because the
peer-reviewed
literature review we've been thinking
about this since we've been
getting our book ready to put out there
because it has new stuff in it and it's
not the standard
thing at all um and i think synthesis is
just a lost
mode yeah right that this is an
important piece of science and
uh it is dismissed because it doesn't
produce
grant money um so anyway yeah it's a
hard question to answer i would say
there's a lot of
popularizer stuff i think um
you know carl sagan was primarily a
popularizer
but changed the way people thought about
things so
made a real contribution yeah i mean
there's there's a lot of different ways
to have contribution and it's not just
doing empirical research and
communicating the research of others
right and it's also not just um doing
empirical research or doing theoretical
research
or pop or communicating the work of
others there is an interplay to be had
in which you
generate new ways of approaching um
kinds of questions and you know that
could largely
be placed into into theory but i think
for instance
some of what we do here um is actually
saying actually
this this paper and this set of papers
out here are doing this wrong
you really have to shift and use this
kind of frame and here's how you would
do that and no we're not going to be the
ones who do the empirical research
but here's what you would do um and
that's related
to like the kind of theoretical work
you've done but it's not the same thing
so it's yet another class
and it's it is a scientific contribution
it just is and it's a necessary one
since
often the empirical scientists doing the
work aren't doing it themselves
but it doesn't fall easily into the
categories that we have yeah
in your discussion with peterson you
mentioned that freud got the edible
complex wrong but you couldn't get to
how
we'd love to hear more on this uh let me
just
say it does not make sense
that selection would wire us
to be attracted sexually
to people that it would be bad to
reproduce with
and then we are obligated to tap into
humanity or to sublimate these things
that's just not the way selection works
selection can easily make you
you know let's put it this way there's a
thing called the westermark effect
the westermark effect uh is the
repulsion the sexual repulsion
that um people raised together
have for each other that is to say if
you are raised with somebody of the
opposite sex
in the same household you will
treat them like a sibling and not find
them
attractive okay that mechanism exists
selection can build such mechanisms why
would it not build the equivalent
mechanism
for parents and offspring obviously it
would and it did
so my point is freud got this wrong
because
he had this sense of selection as a very
crude
force that couldn't build the elegant
thing
and therefore he misinterprets what the
relationship is between parents and
offspring
um or opposite parent opposite sex
parents in their offspring
um so anyway i will uh i will return
there later
all right so we're gonna save a couple
of these for
next time and just um one one more
comment one last question
just for the record i'm pretty sure i
never pronounced it correctly either
hebrew is hard
thank you uh and
um what's a good and tough book on
evolutionary
theory parentheses that's not
divulcation i don't know that word
divulcation
or not devocation um but i
often recommend these two books and in
fact we do so uh we have recommended
texts at the end of the book that we
have coming out
some for each of the chapters but then
also a couple that we describe as
a few denser more technical texts texts
that are nonetheless excellent and they
are
jablonka and lam 2014 evolution in four
dimensions genetic epigenetic behavioral
and symbolic variation in the history of
life
tough but brilliant like just terrific
book
and then mary jane west eberhard in 2003
developmental plasticity and evolution
um which i didn't actually realize until
after
the copy edits went back that um all
three of those authors are women which
is somewhat rare like that's not that
was in no way intentional but yeah um
those are two terrific books that are
definitely challenging but
um but super valuable any any place you
dive in
and you can make meaning out of it you
will you will be better for it
um all right all right i think i think
that is
it for now let us do our uh
announcements as we always do
and uh and then be be done um
so we will be back next week same time
same place 12 30
pacific uh with a um
a an episode not devoted to ads yes
um please join us at either of our
patreons where you get lots of access to
lots of good stuff including um this
monday we'll have a patreon only just
brief test of our new super chat system
uh where we will be engaging the chat a
little bit um
darkhorse.moderategmail.com has
answers to some of your questions please
don't bombard
our moderator but if you have questions
that you think they could answer
go for it and um and maybe that's it for
now
be good to each other and eat good food
and get outside get outside
and don't forget winter is coming
[Music]
you